[Music]
so it's that time of the year again when
everyone starts launching new products
to get those key holiday sales it's also
been a pretty interesting season for the
GPU market as well with the new artic
series from Nvidia but it didn't go as
planned as it should have been in the
first place did it
I mean we're months into the launch and
there still isn't a game that supports
any of the features at the RT x-series
GPUs we're supposed to offer so that
sort of sets the stage for this video
because as it stood aim D didn't really
have anything new from their Radeon
graphics division and that causes an
issue especially at this time of the
year so they had to dig deep into their
past and to come up with this the rx 590
so why don't we go ahead and talk about
the specs and benchmarks and all that
kind of stuff right after this optimize
your desk space with the Sora's new
Graham spectrum TTL keyboard with a
compact steel frame and low-profile key
caps removable cable and sweet
illumination plus your choice of the
Sora's
agile blue or red switches to satisfy
those fingers sieved gram spectrum TTL
keywords for you links below alright so
this is the RX 590 or in this case the
XFX rx 590 fat boy that's right I just
said fat boy and that's exactly what XFX
is calling this thing so keyboard
warriors you're more than welcome to
grow as much as you want in the comments
now the RX 5 nandi isn't really new
because it uses the same four generation
GCN polaris architecture found in the
arcs 480 and rx 580 that's right AMD is
once again using a design that was first
launched about two and a half years ago
this thing has more lives than a cat the
only difference is that they're using a
12 nanometer manufacturing process
instead of the 40 nanometers used on the
rx 580 it really is too bad that Vega
isn't being addressed with this new
process and supposedly AMD has no plans
to change that right now so as you can
see with the specs the updated
manufacturing process has allowed AMD to
take the arcs 580 increase its core
frequency and simply create the rx 590
as a pre overclocked version the claim
is that we should see a 10 to 15%
framerate boost so not all that much
more than what a user overclocked are
580 can achieve so while the rx 580 is
meant to compete against in videos gtx
1066 kilobyte this new card is supposed
to perform a bit above that XFX has
given this card a thirty five megahertz
overclock but that won't amount to any
additional performance even with a
twelve nanometer core there's a huge
jump in power consumption since the
polaris architecture wasn't designed to
operate at such high clock speeds just
to give you an idea that 225 watts is 10
watts more than what nvidia rates there
are TX 20 80 ad and that's pretty crazy
of course pricing had to factor into
this - and that's where I think AMD may
have a winner I mean we really didn't
need a pre overclocked rx 580 but at its
price of $280 it should be pretty
competitive against Nvidia the GTX 1066
gabite goes for around $250 to $290 on
Amazon right now so that's right in line
with the arts 590 by the way you can
find any of these cards I talked about
in the links in the description down
below the problem might come with how
the arcs 590 aligns with the current
state of arcs 580 pricing you see Amy's
board partners have been very aggressive
and you can actually find some examples
like Emma size armor for $210 and power
colors red dragon for $220 honestly this
might cause the arcs 590 to look like a
pretty poor value even before it
launches but there's one more perk I
wanted to talk about when you purchase
an RX 590 or a PC equipped with one
you'll also get three free upcoming
games there's Devil May Cry 5 and the
division two that are due to launch in
March of 2019
while Resident Evil 2 remake should be
out in January all things considered
that's well over a hundred fifty dollars
of free games but they're only valuable
to someone who actually wants them plus
the offer is only good for a limited
time so we can't really take them into
consideration for the rx5 nineties
long term value okay so onto the XFX rx
590 Fat Boy yeah that's probably the
last time I'm going to call that name
but let's take a closer look at this
card and see what it offers so this is
one thick card that has two large fans
and is much more wider than we're used
to basically due to the heat produce
by the overclocked Polaris Core XFX
needed to supersize their hietzing
design and that means it also takes up
two and a half inch slots and is just
over ten and a half inches long now to
feed its hunger for power this rx 590 is
equipped with an 8 pin and a 6 pin power
connector layout and you can actually
see how the heat sings huge heat pipes
sneak around this area it's pretty
impressive but it also goes to show how
AMD did everything they could to squeeze
performance out of their old
architecture the backplane has a cool
design but it's mostly for show since it
doesn't actively cool any components
here so that's it for the overview and
now on to the benchmarks now in order to
keep things even we're gonna be
comparing this arcs 590 I'm not gonna
say the other word but this card to the
msi mech rx 580 the EVGA GTX 1060
superclocked and the EVGA gtx 1070
gaming so let's do this
[Music]
so now that we've gone through the
performance let's take a look at a few
other things first of all how much power
the card sucked down and all I have to
say is that this is pretty concerning
for the RX 590 it looks like AMD push
their Polaris course so far that it now
requires almost as much juice as the
r-tx 2080 I was prepared for this but
wow guys these are some extremely high
numbers for a sub $300 GPU even though
power consumption is high it looks like
XFX has been able to keep temperatures
pretty much under control at 80 degrees
they are higher than what our MSI rx 580
MEK achieved but remember that core is
obviously pushing out a massive amount
of heat
luckily the XFX rx 590 remained pretty
quiet throughout our testing period but
it definitely wasn't the quietest GPU in
these charts but remember at 47 decibels
it won't be annoying in the least and
luckily it didn't exhibit any coil whine
either have you ever wondered how to
build a system you can't hear it starts
with a case my friend the silent base
601 an 801 might be quiet are the tools
for the job
with all the expected airflow options
innovative interiors and awesome tools
panel design and noise absorbing foam in
all the right places
check out the cases you cannot hear in
the description below so guys it's
pretty obvious that the RX 590 is being
launched to capture those Christmas
season sales and aim these struggling to
find ways to keep their current graphics
card stay relevant but I was where did
the RX 5 at 80 and the RX 590 wouldn't
be separate enough to make the refresher
line worth a while well it turns out
that just from a raw performance
standpoint there wasn't much to worry
about personally I think this new card
is perfectly suited for people who want
a budget-friendly GPU that can kick butt
at 1080p while delivering great
performance at 1440p the GTX 1066
gigabyte though it's really more
comfortable gaming at 1080p and the 6
gigabyte frame buffer can be limiter
above that the 590 is just way more
adaptable I really like how the arcs 590
is positioned against the arcs 580 since
its performance increases ranged from
around 7% to 10% at 1440p while 1080p
more of a boost the only problem here is
that AMD's facing the exact same issue
nvidia did when the rth series launched
the older cards are so well priced the
newer ones don't look like a good value
right now you can find an RX 580 for 210
to $220 and the 50 to $60 premium for
the 590 just doesn't seem worth it
unless if you want those free games now
according to AMD v RX 590 is the perfect
upgrade for four to five year old
systems but there's also a little
problem with that story
this thing is a hungry little guy the
XFX card we have sucks down more power
than a gtx 1070 as a matter of fact it
needs about as much power as in RTX 2080
and that's pretty crazy that ND 6 + 8
pin power connector layout might force a
PSU upgrade for older systems and
honestly guys I really like the rx 580
but AMD's obviously trying to push their
purlettes architecture a little bit more
further than it was originally designed
to and that means the power consumption
numbers are huge in comparison to frame
rates now if your system can handle it
this might be an awesome upgrade but I
would also make sure to check the rx 580
prices before taking the plunge
I need bar with hybrid connects thank
you so much watching make sure to check
out some relevant content over here
subscribe to our new boot sequence
channel for the latest tech news and
rumors I'm signing off and I'll see you
guys in the next one